first of all let's just speak about what
we heard overnight with jeremy which is
talking about the um killing by the
americans of ireman al zawahiri i mean
it's a it's a huge scalp to get
yes and it shows that people who have
waged act of war against the united
states will not be able to retire
peacefully to their beds that the united
states is
rightly going after people who have
created led to orchestrated mass murder
in the united states and around the
world now do you think that the west
then was naive or foolish to believe
that the taliban wouldn't end up
harboring terrorists
well
i think that terrorists have been in
afghanistan throughout this period and
that they didn't suddenly all disappear
that's one of the biggest questions it's
just a question of whether we've been
able to to track them down and that we
know the areas in which they have been
and so i think it's great surprise that
a terrorist has been found in
afghanistan nor would have it been a
surprise if terrorists been found in
afghanistan a year ago were slightly
surprised that they were found in
central kabul i mean obviously bin laden
was in the border regions that's where
we think that many of them hide in the
capital
well um i the taliban has not been the
most aggressive suppressor of terrorism
has it so i don't think you should be
surprised by this
so but it's actually it's had a benefit
hasn't it because the americans have
been able to track him down and find him
which may have been more difficult have
you been hiding
in a more remote area i mean how does
this affect any potential engagement
with that government that's running
afghanistan right now do you think well
it's difficult engaging with that
government anyway as we know and that's
been an issue in terms of
providing financing for that government
and the problems that people are having
in afghanistan the very serious
shortages that there are there and the
taliban government is
not a friend of the west to put it at
its mildest i think that's one way of
putting of course let's move on to the
domestic politics now as i said you are
a backer of liz trust you would have
watched the hustings last week
i was actually doing a different debate
on behalf of um
liz in um for the bristol and south
gloucestershire conservative association
and what was the argument you were
making
for people tobacco well three points
really one is that liz is best placed
economically that she has the right
policies that will help the economy grow
and tackle inflation secondly that she's
a fully committed uh brexiteer that she
may have supported remain in 2016 but
she's been one of the cabinet ministers
most supporting me in my breaks to
opportunities role
and third that she's shown leadership by
support she's shown for boris johnson
over ukraine but also her loyalty to
boris johnson now you know that one of
her own economic advisers is concerned
that her economic policies could put
interest rates up seven percent
well i i think that misunderstands what
patrick minford has said actually i i
think that um
the independent bank of england will set
interest rates and we have a serious
inflationary problem and interest rates
have been going up and if you look at
what's happened in the united states
interest rates have gone up much faster
in the united states
that is something done independently by
the bank of england
since 1997 when gordon brown gave them
that independence what the government
has to do is to make sure that fiscal
policy
both works against inflation and helps
the economy to grow and that's the
difficult thing to do because you need
to keep expenditure under control and
plans have been announced how to do that
but you also need to take the burden off
people so they keep more of their own
money to help them through the cost of
living crisis and then you need the
third thing which liz has been strongly
advocating which the supply side reforms
that make the economy more efficient
yeah i mean those tax cutting plans are
one thing and of course you will support
her
moves to do that but this idea of of
kind of borrowing of betting on this 30
billion pound headroom as fancy
economics been described by some some
may describe well differently if you're
going to talk about fairy tale economics
i think suggesting that there will be
income tax cuts many many years into the
future is the finest fantasy because
mr sunak i believe um because
actually you will remember that um
both peel and gladstone said that income
tax was itself a temporary measure which
they had a plan to remove
in the mid 19th century in the 90s so
making suggestions the tax will be cut
in years to come
is the greatest uh fairy tale but when
you take the borrowing figures you've
got to remember that the obr's figure
for 2021 22 was out by 106 billion
pounds the abr thought borrowing would
be 106 billion pounds more than it was
so the fantasy has been with the
forecasters and what we need is to get
the theory of economic policy right and
then apply it and that involves taking
burdens of people
are you completely happy with this idea
of borrowing it doesn't seem to me like
as a true conservatives as you as you
are you would be very happy with the
state borrowing all of this money
against an economic outlook if i can
finish any coming out that we're not
certain about with this ongoing war in
ukraine
governments almost always borrow the
years in which the government actually
pays back debt uh are very few and far
between
what you're talking about is the level
of borrowing and is it proportionate now
if you look at the borrowing of the
state at the moment the total borrowing
excluding the quantity of easing of 875
billion pounds which is owed by the
government to the government so if you
net that off we're under 60 percent of
debt to gdp i think it's a perfectly
sustainable level let's just uh pick up
on some of the uh policy areas that liz
trust was mentioning uh in the past a
few hours this idea of cutting the civil
service i know that you're a fan of that
you left that famous note tending people
to get back
to work but do you think the idea that
uh cutting salaries perhaps perhaps
moving civil servants people who are
paid by the government out of london is
the right way to make sure we level up
the country there are a number of
savings you get by moving school
servants out of london uh you don't have
the london waiting or the london
allowance and property costs are lower
outside london these are really
important benefits and it ties in with
leveling up because you're moving the
jobs out of london but at the same time
we need a smaller civil service we have
91 000 more people working for the civil
service than we did in 2016. we need to
get back to the 2016 level that on its
own will save about three and a half
billion pounds potentially more but it's
not just a civil service is it this
trust is also talking about anyone's pay
for the government's that involves
teachers that involves police officers
involves nurses doesn't it that's not
that's not the plan the discussion at
the moment is around around civil
servants okay and staying on the civil
service then there's this idea of
cutting some 326 diversity officers so
is the job done we don't need to worry
about the civil service being diverse
anymore no i i think ensuring that you
have diversity within employment is the
job of the people making the employment
decisions not somebody who is employed
as a diversity officer
it is a role for aren't they the experts
in how you make sure that our workplace
is diverse and you make sure no i don't
think it works like that i think that
you need to inculcate this in the people
making the employment decisions and in
the
civil service commission to ensure that
you are employing the best people from a
range of backgrounds actually leveling
up is crucial in this moving jobs out of
london because you're then opening it up
to people living all over the country
rather than a very narrow
london focus so i think it's an
important saving and some of the
nonsense that we've been getting we had
a
training program called czech yo
privilege now what earth is that why is
this taking your privilege i think why
is the civil service wasting people's
time with a course that doesn't help
people do their jobs better what do we
want from the civil service we want
people to get their passports on time we
want people to get their driving license
on time we want the probate service to
work all of which have had problems we
also wanted to be a workplace where
people who are from different
backgrounds from diverse backgrounds
feel comfortable to work and won't feel
like
by their colleagues that isn't a job you
give to somebody and you lock away in a
private room to concentrate about it
that is something that you have in the
fundamentals of it and the people who
are making it every five you call the
diversity officers who are working
towards that though are you yes because
i don't believe they're doing anything
useful i don't believe they're adding to
the diversity of the civil service it's
a job creation scheme created by the
work for the woke
mr rees-mogg i don't think that is
entirely fair about all those diversity
offices i think that many of them are
trying to achieve the best that they can
they will be much better employed
getting people the public services that
they need
let's just bring up another little clip
from last night's husting you said you
didn't pay attention because you're
doing something else but this is what
liz trust said about nicholas sturgeon i
think we can play it i feel like i'm a
child of the union that i really believe
we are a family and we're better
together and i think the best thing to
do with nicholas sturgeon is ignore her
i think she's
i think
i'm sorry
it's a bit difficult when she's first
ministered she's got a democratically
elected position just as you i'm sorry
she's an attention seeker
that's what she is
and what we need to do is show the
people of scotland northern ireland and
wales what we are delivering for them
ignore her she's an attention seeker
what's that going to do to the union
when they are agitating to try and split
it up well of course they're agitating
that's what you've got to remember all
that nicholas sturgeon does is campaign
to break the union
education in scotland has been doing
badly health in scotland has been doing
badly public services in scotland have
been failing under the snp and what we
need to do is to hold ms sturgeon to
account for the failings of the scottish
government to deliver services for the
people of scotland and when she's
waffling on endlessly about having a
referendum and going to the supreme
court and all of this we need to be
saying hold on you're doing this because
you are failing to deliver for the
people of scotland and the united
kingdom government will have to deliver
people of scotland
as well i know i know that her point
would be that that is the reason for the
smp that they want to have an
independent scotland and you're not
going to be able to achieve anything
further in terms of discussion by
ignoring them are you
well we have to deal with the arguments
for the united kingdom how did scotland
get through the pandemic it got through
the pandemic because of the support that
there was from the united kingdom as a
whole the united kingdom taxpayer helped
england scotland wales and northern
ireland as a union it was fundamental
the vaccine rather it was a united
kingdom success was the united kingdom
that had the resources and the firepower
to help this country get out of cavite
before other countries to the huge
benefit of our economy whilst nicolas
sturgeon was doing daily press
conferences wanting them in a permanent
lockdown so i think she's very often
wrong she's always moaning
and that we need to focus on how the
union benefits people you're very aware
of how comments like that and what this
trust said last night only calcified the
feeling in scotland that they want to
separate from no they don't what they do
is um the smp gets very cross but of
course the snp gets crossed it's its
permanent default state is a state of uh
mild fury a lot of it confected
what we need to do is make the arguments
about why the united kingdom is
successful for the people of scotland
and how the united kingdom as a whole
has helped the people of scotland when
the scottish government has consistently
failed in key public services